[Applaudissements]
nous parler sébastien patrick mais bref
actions ciblées merci et s'il ya des
gars qui sont sortis dans la rue revel
et rool et st micro et y ajouter un cas
qui veut acheter des trucs attend de lui
je n'ai pas ce qu'ils on a dû aller chez
les pêcheurs dont je vais acheter ça
complètement ils sont complètement fou
mais on la savait sur les pages il ya
deux coupables alors là on l'avait le
cas regardez regardez je sais rien et ça
c'est je vous leur voix a alors c'est
rien c'est un petit kalaja c'est sûr eh
ben c'est pas mal comme ça aussi ça
marque vraiment tu te fais avoir à
chaque fois il se croyait en moi
pourquoi je leur demande des choses et
pourquoi qu'est ce qu'ils regardent
l'émission en régime vers un stade 2 et
merck ont peur passée jean michel maire
au ralenti qui regardent police et la
paix dont géant est un génie va ici et
nous recaler ça dans un instant où
partout cet été
donnez moi je vais vous expliquer dans
l'espace on n'a pas le plan b enrichi
dont on voit les images qu'ils veulent
c'est mon plaisir en fait je suis battu
envoyés maintenant ils sont comme
discuter du programme nombre décimal
merci c'est la dernière fois que vous
demande quelque chose